"See" takes place about 600 years after
a viral apocalypse.
Those who survive are left blind,
and the world has gone back to
a tribal culture.
It's so very different.
It's just something
that has never been done before.
We've been working to build this world,
what it would look like,
what it would feel like.
The world has been rebuilding itself,
both in the natural environment
that we see here,
but also the kind of people
and how they live together.
There is a beauty about it, mankind,
with nothing to distract
other than to keep life going.
The idea is that the human beings
who did all the damage to the Earth
in the first place can't see it.
Then vision comes back.
What is it?
Something's different.
The children.
They have the ability to see.
Characters who are
blind or visually impaired
haven't often had an opportunity
to portray aspects outside of
showing off their disability.
I train actors how we move
through the world,
and help them understand
how people utilize their senses
in a different way.
They will come for us.
Prepare for a long journey.
Action-packed.
So much cool stuff in a world
that we've never seen before.
This is our home.
We are one.
And we fight as one.